welcome to the man of recaps this is
attack on titan season four part two
part one left off right before our big
battle as the forces of marley were
coming to the island of paradise for a
counter-attack and leading the assault
is our old friend reina who is the
armored titan and he and aaron have an
epic rematch and meanwhile aaron's
half-brother zeke yeager who was blown
up at the end of last season but he has
titan healing he's fine captain levi
ackerman not so much unfortunately hanji
manages to get him to safety though
anyways he comes to join the battle as
the beast titan but remember he's
fighting against marley now zeke's real
goal is to touch aaron uniting the
founding titan with a member of royal
blood they can actually use its power he
wants to sterilize all aldeans thinking
that's the way to end their suffering
but if these two touch they could also
use the founding titan's power to
unleash the million titans that make up
the walls and destroy the world in an
event called the rumbling so marley's
main goal is not to let that happen they
blast zeke to take him out but he's not
dead so now he has to play his trump
card he screams transforming all the
parody seldins that drink the wine
inspected with the spinal fluid into
titans they rampage on the marlian
forces and for the first time since the
early seasons we've got a titan attack
now remember little falco accidentally
drank some of the wine so he's a titan
ii now and rushes over to attack rhina
but wait who's this come to sacrifice
himself to save reina it's their other
friend who has the jaw titan and oh now
falco eats him got the power of the jaw
so now ryan continues to beat a baron
but aaron yeager pulls a trick he
hardens to trap rhino there then leaves
his body and makes a run for it because
zeke is still alive and he's gonna touch
him all of aaron's friends by the way
have been kept in the dark as aaron's
true intentions it's like wait does he
actually want to do his brother zeke
sterilization plan that doesn't sound
like him armin's like yo aaron must have
a secret plan he'll probably want to use
the founding titan's power to threaten
the rumbling and save us all for marley
so we gotta go help him but now who's
this it's little gobby with a sniper
rifle boom wow she blows aaron's head
clean off but if there's one thing we
know about zeke he loves playing
baseball and he makes the diving catch
and aaron's brain was just alive enough
they've successfully done it they are in
the coordinate of all aldeans with their
founder emir but zeke is chained up here
he's the one with the royal blood but
apparently he has no power it's aaron
with the founding titan who can decide
what to do so since aaron has the power
it's like yo psych i was just pretending
to support your sterilization plan i got
my own plans but now zeke is like yo
double psych i was just pretending to
not have power here so you would reveal
your true intentions zeke wants to
convince aaron that his plan is the
right one so they go on our trip through
their father grisha yeager's memories
zeke wants to show aaron how their
father never cared about him all he ever
wanted was an aldian uprising for
revenge against marley but turns out
grisha decided to abandon his plans for
revenge and just live in peace with the
sun aaron that he loves of course later
when the series started and the titans
breached shiganshina he went to the
royal family like please you have to
stop him and even then he decided not to
go through with stealing the founding
titan's powers because it would involve
you know massacring these kids but then
aaron yeager starts talking to his
father who can hear him it's like what's
up dad i'm the spirit of your son from
the future here to tell you you gotta go
through with it trust me so somehow it
was aaron yeager himself who started
this whole adventure to get to this
present moment cause now it's like
triple psych bro i actually do somehow
have the power here so now zeke tells
amir to sterilize all the aliens and
aaron goes over to stop her and this
whole series has been a mystery who
actually was amir and how did she end up
with titan power turns out she was not
actually ld and she was from a peaceful
village conquered by the aldians somehow
she fell into this water with a weird
jellyfish vertebrae thing that oh turned
her into the first titan but amir spent
her whole life as a slave she only knew
obedience to the alien king fritz and so
used her titan powers to join his army
and help conquer the world in fact she
had king fritz's children and one day
sacrificed herself to save him to keep
the titan power they had her children
eat her and that's how we got the nine
titans and the spirit of amir lives on
here in the coordinates still a slave to
the royal family so now aaron grabs her
like yo it's time to stop being a slave
it's time for you to fight back and
she's like you know what bro you're
right so somehow she passes the founding
titan power to aaron and now we realize
aaron's true plan is not to threaten the
rumbling to keep marley away but to
unleash it right now yes the walls are
coming down
a million colossal titans headed to the
mainland the rumbling is here as for
aaron himself he transforms into the
biggest titan yet and we don't get a
full shot of it but it's apparently a
weird slithering thing and now aaron
psychically talks to all the aldians
like hey what's up guys it's like look
the outside world hates us and that's
just not gonna change the only way my
home the island of paradise can ever
really be safe is if we wipe out every
other person on the planet and yeah i
mean that's obviously awful but it's
rough cause he's kind of right so the
rumbling is happening and doesn't look
like anyone can stop it remember in part
one of the season the jaegerists led a
coup to take over parodies they're led
by this red-haired guy flock and they're
all real happy they're like yeah we can
live in peace and restart life on earth
but unfortunately he's got kind of a
dictator vibe and executes anyone not on
his side this leaves any marlin
survivors like peak the cart titan as
enemies of the state and also enemies of
the state are commander hanji and an
injured but alive captain levi it's like
yo we're not with the yeagerists let's
be allies jean seems like he sided with
the aegis but when they bust on in there
oh they eat him but actually it was a
rescue he was working with them and all
of aaron's friends are in on the plan
and they recruit another old friend it's
annie yeah when erin took down the walls
he undid all hardened titans including
her shell so for almost the whole series
she's been sitting there in the basement
but now annie is back and so all our
main characters are on the same side
it's been complicated as everyone's had
different motivations to fight to
different times but now they all agree
killing everyone in the world is not the
right move they gotta stop aaron and
they have a plan they figure they can
catch up to aaron by using the flying
boat aka the plane that mikasa's
relatives the azmobito family brought
but the yegarists are guarding it and
our crew doesn't want to fight them
because you know those were their
friends they try to pretend they're
still on their side but long story short
flock doesn't buy it and it is tragic as
connie has no choice but to kill this
guy who was his friend but annie and
reina bust in and transform yes the
female titan back in action with the
armored and weirdly now they're on our
side so it's an epic battle at the port
as our crew fights the jaegerists but
it's not really triumphant like back
when they were killing titans because
these friends are jaegerists aren't even
bad they're just on different sides and
everyone's doing what they gotta do to
survive and even with the titans on our
side our crew's now winning the
yagarists have perfected the art of
titan fighting so it's time for young
falco to go on in help and broom he
transforms to the jaw titan uh his
version's hairy for some reason in the
end flock tries to take out the ship so
they can't get to air in but oh someone
shoots him and he was the hero in his
own story but unfortunately not in this
one with their leader gone mikasa goes
on a rampage just absolutely tearing
through the rest of the jaegerists yeah
she is terrifying no one wants to fight
her so our crew wins the day turns out
the plane's not ready to fly so they
gotta tow it to the mainland where they
can repair it then hopefully catch up
with aaron and the rumbling but the
question is how are they gonna stop
aaron he's still our crew's best friend
they hope they can just talk him out of
it but everyone else is skeptical mikasa
thinks back to happier days when their
crew first went on an undercover
scouting mission to marley at the time
they had high hopes that they would be
able to come out to the world like hey
we are not devils we don't want to
conquer you please let's all live in
peace but aaron yeager was not so
optimistic and he had a moonlit
conversation with mikasa where the
question finally came up after all this
time do aaron and mikasa like each other
romantically she said no you're like my
brother but it seems like that was kind
of a lie anyway our crew soon discovered
that the world hated them more than they
even thought and that's when aaron left
them and went on his own secret plan to
launch the first strike attack on marley
and now off the marlin coast the entire
world has banded together gotten all the
guns they have pointed to stop the
rumbling and they fire everything
they've got at the hilariously swimming
titans but it's not enough the fleet is
quickly obliterated and now the rumbling
titans are at the shore a million titans
ready to stomp the world flat and as if
that weren't enough right behind him
they've got aaron's massive new titan
body that we still don't get like a full
look at but i mean it looks weird how
will this story come to an end find out
in attack on titan season 4 part 3 which
is allegedly actually the real final
final part
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]